And now it's the old scout master.
I went to camp and there was a very inspiring speech by one of the counselors
about starting from the bottom and working your way to the top.
That's right. Didn't spend a whole lot of time in his department,
He was the aquatics instructor.
Hey, this is podcast number 127..
Hey, hey,
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green.
If you can't tell, I'm kind of working on a little bit of a summer cold.
Wow, Summer cold in the heat.
Yeah, it's great times here.
Let's take a look at the mailbag.
Bob White's Blather tweeted us and said thanks for mentioning
Bob White Blather in last week's podcast.
That's Frank Maynard, Bob White's Blather.
I mentioned you again, Frank,
So the mailbag's been a little thin this week.
I am sure that everybody's out camping.
I certainly hope so.
But here's what I want you to do this week:
Tell me your favorite story from camp.
Go to scoutmastercgcom, follow the links to the shout-out page
and you'll find out how to leave a shout-out for your troop
or one of your patrols or one of your scout's accomplishments,
or indeed one of your fellow leader's accomplishments,
And you can also just tell me a great story
about summer camp this summer.
That's really all that you need to do.
Scoutmastercgcom,
Find the shout-out page
You can call in. You can do that,
Or you can just send me an email, scoutmastercgatverizonnet,
and we'll talk more about how to keep in touch
when we get to the end of the podcast.
But this week in scoutmastership, in seven minutes or less,
we're going to talk about troop meetings
And then we've got an email question
and that's going to do it for this podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less?
Not too many boys.
If you ask them, go ahead and ask them. ask your scouts.
Not too many scouts would say that
one of the big reasons that they joined scouting
was to attend troop meetings.
No, they want adventure, right.
They want to have fun with their friends.
They want to have fun,
They want to learn new skills,
They want to explore the outdoors.
But we put an awful lot of effort
and an awful lot of time into troop meetings
And troop meetings could be the catalyst
for all these great things that boys want to do as scouts.
They have to be fast-paced and interesting
and varied and engaging right,
And they need to lead towards those
exciting troop activities in the outdoors.
They need to be the kind of glue
that holds a troop together.
If we look at a troop meeting
as a couple of hours to fill once a week,
we're going to scramble for all kinds of different resources
and just try and program two hours of stuff.
I'm going to suggest that that's not a very good approach.
Let's look at-
Let's assume- you go camping once a month.
That means you have two or three troop meetings
to prepare for a camping trip
And let's say you meet for an hour and a half,
two hours every week.
So you've got somewhere between
four and six hours of trip preparation time
And that's what those troop meetings can be.
You've also got other purposes that you can serve.
It motivates.
Are your troop meetings motivating?
Do they motivate scouts?
Do they motivate them to be better scouts
and to encourage them to learn
and practice scouting skills
and to advance in rank?
Do the meetings strengthen patrols?
Do they promote patrol spirit?
And, more importantly,
are your troop meetings a laboratory of leadership?
Are they allowing scouts to exercise leadership?
And troop meetings are especially effective at this
because they need to be planned,
organized and carried out by the boys themselves.
Scouts take ownership in the meetings
and they're empowered to lead the events
that make up each meeting.
Boys need the resources
to make their troop meetings successful
And as adult leaders
we can provide support and guidance
that will allow them to make the most of those resources.
But perhaps the most important resource
for them in developing effective troop meetings
is the troop meeting plan.
Is there some kind of framework?
I'm going to talk about the one that
we all hear about all the time.
It has seven distinct steps.
It's a format that's been developed
over many years of scouting. experience
Presents scouts with an effective framework
to put together troop meetings
And so if they work within this framework,
it will give them some focus.
It will give them a framework
for enjoyable, productive,
meaningful and timely troop meetings.
So there's seven distinct steps.
There's the pre-opening part of the meeting.
There's the opening part of the meeting.
There's usually some kind of presentation
or skills instruction.
There's a time for patrols to meet.
There's an inter-patrol activity.
There's a closing
And then there's that time after the meeting.
Let's say your troop meeting is 7 o'clock.
Your adult and youth leaders
begin to arrive around 6.30
in preparation for the meeting.
Now we take advantage of that time
in my troop to have the patrol leaders
council get together
and go over whatever plans
they have for that meeting
And just to kind of get things
set up and staged and ready to go.
But there's also this pre-opening,
because as boys begin to arrive
for the meeting, as scouts begin to arrive
for the meeting, there should be
something going on-
Any kind of a game or project
or something like that-
designed so that the scouts
can join in as they show up.
And that person who is in charge of that
should be ready to start about 15 minutes early,
Right,
And keep that activity going all the way up
until it's time to begin.
And when we begin, we're at the opening,
And when we begin the meeting,
that's the opening of the meeting.
That is, the senior patrol leader
is going to run that,
He's going to call the meeting to order,
He's going to have the scouts
line up or circle up
in some kind of formation
And we're going to make sure we do that by patrols.
And there needs to be
kind of formal opening,
A flag ceremony
saying the Scott oath and law, things like that.
Some people change that from week to week.
We have a pretty standard
approach to that, But
anything that says: okay,
here's a tiny, here's a little bit
of ceremony, This is serious what we're doing.
Here's the ideals.
It's going to set the tone for
what happens that evening.
Now, after that opening, we're going to move on to
skills instruction. Skills instruction
is a pretty tough nut to crack
for a lot of people.
The best thing to do
is to relate whatever
is happening in the meeting to the upcoming
outing. So try and
work that skills instruction there.
somehow We'll do that.
Sometimes we'll do
an introduction to a merit badge-
Not a merit badge, because
I don't, because merit badges
really don't belong at troop
meetings. You know, I think
a lot of people do that. I think that's a
mistaken approach. Don't
put merit badges in troop meetings. Don't
do merit badges instruction at troop meetings.
You're kind of shortcut part of the merit
badge process. when you do that. You can
do the introduction to one, Have a counselor
there, Have them talk about it, Have them try out
some skills. It has to be hands on,
It has to be engaging, It has to be interesting.
But whatever this skill instruction is,
it shouldn't be a bunch of scouts sitting
in chairs listening to somebody talk
And it certainly should be scouts
instructing scouts whenever possible.
So after the skill instruction
you're going to move on to patrol meetings And at
patrol meetings the patrols have some things to do.
They need to take attendance,
collect dues, They need to
plan the patrol's involvement in the
upcoming troop activities.
They probably need to select a menu for
a hike or a camp out.
They need to assign patrol members to
specific tasks And they need to
work out any other
things that the patrol
needs to work out. at that point
The length of the patrol meeting
really depends on how much business the patrols
have to handle. It might be 5 minutes, It might
be 20 minutes And that's up to
the senior patrol leader, as he plans the meeting out,
to have that ready to go.
It's also good for the patrol
leaders to have a framework
for their patrol meetings. You know
they'll be a part of it that's business,
a part of it that's discussion, a part of it
that's planning. But they also need
a good framework to work with And they
need to keep the pace up and they need to keep it
moving and engaged. They need to avoid distractions
and they need to get their patrol get
their work done and get ready to go,
Following the patrol meeting and inter-patrol
activity that you know maybe 15
to 20 minutes. it can be a game,
It can be based on the skills instruction
that you've already had. You know, guys, when we
come back from patrol meetings we're going to have
a not-tying relay or something like that.
So you might want to take some of your
time at patrol meeting
to practice some of those skills.
Inter-patrol competitions should definitely have
some kind of programmatic tie-in
so that where it relates
to the other things that the boys are doing
and the adding that they're preparing to go on,
And then the meeting
closes And that is where
the scout master gets to say
something. At this point,
when we get to this point in the meeting, the scout
master should have been observing,
Should have been, you know, towards
the back of the room watching
and seeing what's going on. Let the senior
patrol leader go through the leadership
things. Let him make a couple
of mistakes, help him out if he wants
your assistance.
Don't barge in and ask him if he wants your
assistance. Let him know that you're there,
that you'll help him out, And you know
you have time to do a scout master's
minute. And then- and I think it's
always a good idea in closing
the meeting to have some kind of a formal
way of closing- We close
with the scout master's benediction. May the great master
of all scouts be with us to a meeting again.
A very simple thing. And then
after the meeting, you know
you may have some
issues to deal with in resetting the meeting
space back up- If it's a shared meeting
space, you know cleaning
up and things like that. And
we usually have
a brief
stand-up meeting with
the patrol
leaders council. The senior patrol leader will get
the patrol leaders to go over his plans
for the next meeting and discuss
them and discuss what needs to happen
in the ensuing week, What kind of
information needs to get out to scouts, and things like that.
Seven pieces of
that framework: A pre-opening, an
opening, skills instruction,
patrol meetings,
an inter-patrol competition,
a closing and a time after
the meeting where plans for the next one
are discussed. briefly, Using a
framework is important And
I think I would encourage you: if
you are doing merit badge
sessions at troop meetings right now,
rethink that.
Rethink that.
That was the thing that we did for
a number of years
And we
thought about it, talked with
the patrol leaders council about it
And they were quite amazed that they did not have
to do merit badges at troop meetings
because we had done it for so long.
They just thought: well, this is what you do,
And I think they were happier
about the way that their troop meetings go after that.
I hope that helped.
This is Cliff Jacobson and you're
listening to the Scout Master
Podcast with Clark Green.
E-mail- that is folks,
And here's an answer
to one of your e-mails.
E-mail- that is folks,
And here's an answer to one of your
e-mails.
Recent e-mail I received.
My son's
scout troop went to summer camp
for two weeks.
My son could only go for the first week
because he had summer school.
The first week all merit badges
were to be earned within the troop,
not with the camp.
That week there was a
demerit point system to earn the right
to go to the trading post.
My son was sent home
on the second day of camp.
He asked the Scout Master if he could go
fishing and he was allowed to go
And then he went to the trading post.
He was seen by the senior
patrol leader and he was sent home
and the Scout Master says that he no longer trusts him.
He was told he cannot
come to any scout meetings for three months.
My son is working on
his Eagle project but the Scout Master
said he's to have no contact
with any of the scouts.
I know my son disobeyed,
but I think this is a little excessive.
The sender of that email is going to remain anonymous
for obvious reasons,
And yeah,
that does sound kind of excessive
and I'm sorry that you find yourself
in this unfortunate position.
Unfortunately,
I hear from folks with similar stories
from time to time.
Now the advice I'm going to give you
is conditional on your side of the story,
and that's only one side.
You say the Scout Master was provoked
to take these measures for
a fairly simple thing.
You know,
a boy said he was going to go fishing
and then he stopped by the trading post.
he probably wasn't supposed to
but he did it anyway.
You know that's aggravating.
There's some hints in that question
that kind of indicate this Scout Master
may be
being a little unreasonable,
I think, certainly in the
punishment that he made it out.
I mean a system of demerits controlling
the Scout's visits to the trading post.
It sounds a little,
a little bit on the edge
of somebody with some
control problems to me.
And sending a Scout home
for, you know,
basically telling a lie
and doing something that he wasn't supposed to do.
I can understand that to a certain
extent, but the boy just
went to the trading post.
There's got to be a more constructive
way to deal with this, shouldn't there?
And then not only sending him home,
but giving him three months
suspension
from troop activities.
this is not a Scout
who's just, you know,
dithering away his time and everything like that.
the boy's working on an Eagle project,
And so this Scout Master
got angry.
And you know what? sometimes you get angry
as a Scout Master. sometimes you lose your temper,
sometimes you do things that you regret.
Welcome to the world of being a human being
right
Now. frankly,
this Scout could be a bit of a pain.
I mean, he may have a real attitude.
He may be, like, consistently
poorly behaved-
And there's nothing personal there,
It's definitely a possibility.
But even if
this Scout is a real pain
and he's really poorly behaved,
one would hope
that a Scout Master would be a little more understanding,
a little less drastic
and a little more constructive in his reactions.
I mean, every teenage boy
has their moments.
Now, as far as how you
as a parent deal with this,
there is little to
no chance you're going to change
the Scout Master's mind
or the way he's doing things.
You know,
he may be one of these guys
who involve themselves in scouting
and they become tyrannical little tin pot gods.
If it were up to me,
I'd toss all these guys out on their ear,
but it's not up to me.
There are just a couple of basic ways forward.
You and your son
stay with this troop,
and it's tin pot god of a Scout Master.
or you find another troop,
Depending on the kind of relationship you have with the guy.
maybe you can sit down,
maybe you can speak with him,
maybe you can reason with him
a little bit.
but it doesn't sound really likely
because, like I said, there are some things
that you've indicated in the email
that kind of lead me to believe,
hmm, maybe tin pot god.
There's some things that you've said in the email
that kind of lead me to believe
that this guy is kind of that way.
you know,
and I really don't know if you're going to be able
to make any big changes
Now-
you've got to sit down with your son
and you've got to say: look, you know
you did something absolutely wrong
and I think
that the punishment that you're receiving
is a little drastic
and I'm willing to support
any way you want to handle this going forward,
And I don't think
we're going to change the Scout Master.
I don't think we're going to change the way
that they do things.
They're not the only shell in town.
We can go and look at other troops
if that's what you'd like to do,
and I support you.
I'm disappointed in your actions,
but you know I will.
but I'm going to.
I'm going to be as supportive
and
I want to be as supportive
and encouraging as possible
and I want to see you become an Eagle Scout
and I want to see you
happy in Scouts.
So that's the way
you're going to work with your son to try and figure out
what your next step is.
I will tell you that boys
are in Scouting to do things with their friends
and I'm going to assume your son has friends
in the troop that we're speaking of.
As much as you may not like
the way the Scout Master does things,
your son's friendships are likely
to be much more important to him.
It's really got to be
his decision in the end.
So if he's willing to go visit other troops
and see if there's one where the Scout Master
is not such a problem,
and if you decide to change troops,
do this for me. would you
Just ask the folks at your son's current troop
for his records. thank them for their help this far
and walk away.
Don't recriminate, don't holler,
don't do anything else
other than leave.
Changing troops is actually
a pretty simple thing to do.
it's not that big a deal
administratively.
Again, your son's decision to make
what I'm telling you is based on
30 plus years in Scouting.
you're not going to change
this Scout Master
and the culture of that troop.
it doesn't happen.
If you must press your case,
if you really think that you have
to do something,
don't talk to the Scout Master.
speak to the committee chair
or the charter organization representative
or indeed the head of the chartering organization.
Now,
clearly, what you've described to me-
and again I've got one side of the story,
that kind of reaction
to a fairly
one of the mill kind of thing happening.
that's pretty antithetical
to the way I see Scouting.
It doesn't sound as though
it's compromising the physical safety of children.
it just sounds like
you got a Scout Master with a bit of an attitude.
you've got a right
to be upset about that.
it's a bad situation,
but you're going to teach your son a great deal
by the way you handle it.
you're going to maintain your temper, keep your cool
and you're going to work with them.
this kind of thing happens.
boys are boys,
and not that that excuses bad behavior.
but we have to understand
sometimes as leaders,
that this is not a personal
slight on us. when a boy does something,
this is not
aimed at us personally,
and if we take it to
personally we tend to overreact.
I know I do
so. if you have a question
that you think we could help you with,
tell me and you're going to find out how to do that
in just a moment.
well, thanks for listening
to this edition of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how you can keep in touch.
you can read the scoutmaster blog at
scoutmastercgcom
and you can subscribe to receive updates
by email to the blog.
you can also subscribe to the scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes.
please leave a comment or review or rating.
we sure do appreciate that.
you can access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio.
you get details how to do that at stitchercom.
remember what I said at the top of the podcast:
call, leave a voicemail, comment or question.
go to scoutmastercgcom
and look for the shout out page.
that's right.
you can experience the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
you can follow us at
scoutmaster blog on facebook,
tweet scoutmastercg on twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle,
search for scoutmastercg
on google plus.
now, if what I just said makes absolutely no sense to you
whatsoever, well, you can email me.
that's right.
send me your comments, your questions and your wild ideas
at scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
oh happens, no,
it's just me talking into a microphone
through a summer cold, trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders and maybe have a little bit of fun
along the way.
before we leave you, let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and group camping
why? thank you, sir,
until next time
you.